J'espérais que nous pourrions commencer par quelques
idées sur ce que vous pensiez
pendant votre isolement, bien sûr, oui, je
peux dire que je peux faire mieux que cela, je peux,
je peux vous dire exactement ce que je
pensais, j'ai l'impression d'être arrivé à certains
des  des questions plus importantes, je ne suis pas
les réponses, mais certainement des choses
qui m'ont empêché de dormir la nuit,
comment se fait-il
qu'Aquaman puisse contrôler les baleines et les baleines
sont des mammifères n'a même pas de sens
parlons de l'exercice alors 10 jours
10 nuits c'est long  il est temps pour un homme
d'être seul avec lui-même et que faites-
vous quand vous étudiez seul
bien sûr pour ma mission trouver de nouvelles façons de
nouvelles techniques pour soulager la tension j'avais l'
impression d'avoir 15 ans en
tant que première femme
commandant d'un  Mission Ares Je
me demandais si vous ressentiez une pression supplémentaire
sur les niveaux de responsabilité déjà intenses
auxquels vous êtes confrontés en termes
de mission avez-vous des craintes non je suis
allemand nous ne ressentons pas la peur bien c'est
difficile comme ça  en tant que médecin vous
Je suis habitué à des environnements très stressants, des questions de vie ou de mort au quotidien, mais oui, je sais que je suis très confiant
que nous allons botter
le cul dr martien.  [ __ ] d'âme, qu'est-ce qui me donne
cet autre équipage comme mes
pensées personnelles ouais Watney est le préféré de tout le monde,
je veux dire, je comprends si vous
allez dire que nos enfants ne connaissent peut-être pas les baleines
un mammifère et si Aquaman a besoin d'un gros poisson,
les enfants vont dire pourquoi  s'il
n'appelle pas une baleine et vous n'allez pas arrêter
le spectacle et expliquer ce que les baleines sont des
mammifères parce que l'enfant ne sait pas que les
baleines sont des mammifères, alors vous savez que Martinez
pense vraiment qu'il est drôle parfois j'ai
des films dans la tête vous voyez ce qui se passe
Goodfellas d'accord d'accord ce qu'il y a dans
le coffre ce qu'il y a dans le coffre euh Joe
Pesci était incroyable Luis est assez dur à cuire
donc vous savez pour mon dossier j'ai été diplômé en tête
de ma classe de l'Académie navale avez-
vous déjà été dans un sous-marin
avec lequel vous essayez de dormir  les craquements et le
grincement on dirait que quelqu'un
écrase lentement et violemment une canette de soda dans
laquelle vous êtes à l'intérieur J'ai dormi comme un
bébé dès le premier jour, donc non, je ne pense pas que
la pression supplémentaire d'être la première
femme à commander une mission  vers Mars  ça
va être trop intense mais merci pour
les dix jours là-bas c'était
assez éclairant